- Does it bother you that you
didn't get Rookie of the Year?
- No, it doesn't bother me.
I blame myself.
- [Announcer:] Young circles,
floats. It hits.
- You're up here.
- I'm up here. I'm up here.
- Then you got to go
between your legs.
- [Announcer:]
Three-pointer for Trae.
- But OK. Honestly,
after that first game
when you said it's over,
did you feel so silly?
- Oh, trust me.
- [Laughs]
- Trust me.
I was sick.
♪♪♪
- What's up, everybody?
It's Trae Young here
with the Atlanta Hawks
and your girl here
is back in A-Town,
and I know she got
a lot of questions for me.
So we're about to
"Take it There"
with Taylor Rooks.
- [Announcer:]
Trae with the runner.
- [Announcer 2:]
Oh, my goodness,
Trae getting 'em back
quickly.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor Rooks:] Thank you
for spending time with me
after practice.
- Of course, of course.
- I'm happy to be back home.
- I'm happy to be here with you,
so it's going to be fun.
- Are you loving Atlanta?
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- I love it here.
- A lot of times people
say, like,
you are the star Atlanta needs.
What do you think they mean
when they say that about you?
- I mean, that excitement,
that kind of buzz,
that national attention,
and I just think they needed
someone to come in,
bring that fire back
to the city of Atlanta.
- How wild is it though
to think, like,
if you continue this trajectory
that you're at right now...
- Mmhmm.
- Like, your name is with,
like, the Dominiques.
- Yeah, that's, it's crazy.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy to think sometimes.
It's like,
I look up at the rafters,
like, in our gym and you see
Pistol Pete,
you see Dominique,
you see legends
and then people tell me
all the time, if I stay healthy
and things go my way
and continue this way,
that one day my, my jersey
could be hanging up there.
- Now it is no secret.
Anybody who follows me knows
I go very hard for the Hawks.
- Mmhmm.
- I am a Hawks fan.
- [Laughs]
- The thing, though,
that whenever
I talk about the Hawks,
people are like,
"They're losing.
They're not even that good."
But I'm like, we're young.
- Yeah.
- Like, we're figuring it out.
But how long can
"We're young"
be an excuse for losing?
- Not very long.
Not very long.
I think if you look
at our team though,
we've started five guys
22 and younger.
So it's not an excuse
by any means,
but it's just reality,
to be honest with you.
Trust me, it'll change soon.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:] So let's talk about
draft night.
- [Trae Young:] Mmhmm.
- Obviously that is a night
that has got to stay
with you forever.
- Yeah.
- Give me a play-by-play
of how the day and night
happened.
- I remember looking on TV,
just wanted to see
what people were thinking about
where I was going to go,
and I was looking at everybody
saying I was going to go 12, 14.
I was talking to my agent
like, "Is this for real?"
He's just like,
"Man, turn off everything."
Get to the draft.
Sitting down at the table,
third pick's about to get
called, it's Atlanta.
The commissioner comes out
and they say,
"Luka Doncic is the third pick."
So as he's walking
across the stage,
my dad's sitting next to me
and my agent's right behind me.
They come up and they say,
"You're going to Atlanta."
I said, "What do you mean?
They didn't, like,
they didn't just call me."
- [Taylor:] So you didn't know
till right there.
- [Trae:] I didn't know till
right there,
but all day my dad
and my agent,
they knew that they were
going to trade up for me,
and I was still confused.
And so my hands were
sweating so hard.
And when the fourth pick
got called,
Memphis was called,
and I was, like, crying.
Like, I was nervous, didn't know
how I was going to react.
Didn't want to trip up
the steps going up.
And then they announced my name,
and then I got across the stage,
got down,
talked to Maria Taylor,
and she was just telling me,
yeah,
they just traded me to Atlanta.
- [Taylor:] So when you
look at that night,
are you like, "OK,
I wish they would have
told me earlier in the day,"
or are you happy with how it...
- I'm happy with how, I'm happy
with how it happened.
I think if I'd have known, maybe
I wouldn't have been so nervous,
but I don't think I would've
really appreciated
the moment like I did,
so it was cool.
- Mmhmm.
You know, if I was you,
I would be so annoyed
with the constant
Luka/Trae talk.
- [Trae:] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] Just because
you're going
to be tied forever.
And I mean, I don't know
if you can really help it.
But does it bother you that
that's what it's always
going to be?
- Uh...
I mean, to be honest with you,
like, it's annoying,
but it's going to be,
it's going to be that way
until we're both,
we're both done playing.
So might as well
just embrace it.
- [Announcer:] Long deep three
over Deandre Ayton.
- [Announcer 2:]
He is never out of range.
- [Taylor:] With the way
basketball has evolved,
should we move
the three-point line?
- I think maybe we should add
a four-point line.
- Ooh!
- [Trae:]
I think that'd be,
I think that would change
the game up a little bit.
And the way guys
are hitting half-court shots,
making that four points,
maybe that'd be cool.
- [Taylor:]
Does it bother you
that you didn't get
Rookie of the Year?
- No, it didn't bother me.
It doesn't bother me too much.
I blame myself for, for not
getting Rookie of the Year.
I didn't put myself
in the best situation early on,
the way I started,
and I came on super hot late,
but it was already too late.
I mean, so for me,
I can't really be mad
at anybody besides myself.
- No, I will say obviously
I follow a lot of
Hawks people on Twitter.
Your first year, there were
some shaky moments.
- Mmhmm.
- And there was a lot of people
that were like, "All right,
should've got Luka."
- Yeah.
- What did you think
when that was happening?
- Just wait,
it's going to change.
It's going to,
it's going to be better.
Even when I had
my struggling moments,
I think everybody really,
really overreacted.
I remember I, I didn't shoot
very well my first game,
and it was all
on SportsCenter,
all everybody could talk about
on all the sports channels
is just, I mean, how major
of a bust I could be.
I just took it
with a grain of salt
and just wanted people
to keep that same energy
when it turned over, so that's,
that's how I looked at it.
- Your iconic tweet,
of course, was,
the apology should be as loud
as the disrespect was.
- Mm-hmm.
- Have the apologies been
as loud?
- They were, they were loud.
There's never going to be
100% people on your side.
- Was there a game for you
where you were like,
"This is it.
This is the turning point"?
- When we played in Denver,
had some guys out,
whenever our third best player
got hurt.
John was out for me
to go off in Denver
against a really good team
and get a win on the road.
I think that was, like, one of
those moments where it's like,
"All right, like,
I can do this."
- You do have some vets
on this team,
but it's not like you have
a super strong vet core.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Vet presence on this team.
- Who do you lean on
in the NBA?
- A guy like Chris Paul.
Growing up,
going to Thunder games,
I've known and talked
to KD, Russ.
Those are my guys, those are
my guys I could really,
I can call,
talk to, ask for advice.
- What is the best
piece of advice
that Chris Paul has given you?
- Stay aggressive.
He, I remember after
we played 'em last year,
my rookie year, just
I played really well out there
and he just,
he wants me to just continue
to be aggressive, just always be
in attack mode
in wanting just to score,
just to be in attack mode
to get other people involved,
whatever it was.
- And what's the best
piece of advice
that Russell Westbrook
has given you?
- [Trae:] Uh, Russ has given me
a lot of advice over the years.
I remember when I was a kid,
um, I was going to
a Thunder game.
He walked out
with some crazy clothes on,
which he always does,
but I asked him about some,
some clothes he had on,
and he said,
"Maybe one day
you can get some of these."
It was, I think
at the time it was
Christian, like, Louboutins,
and it was some spiked shoes
with the red bottoms.
So I'll never forget that,
and, uh...
I think after we played 'em
this year,
he was telling you about his,
his first year in the league,
they lost 27 games in a row.
So it's like,
just to stay with it,
just be that leader
on my team.
- [Announcer:]
That's his range.
- [Announcer 2:]
And Young from center court!
Yes!
[Cheering]
- [Taylor:] You being
an all-star
is kind of a debate around
because the Hawks
are a "losing team."
I even got into a fight
about this on my Twitter show...
- I'm sorry.
- But that's a different story.
Um, what should be the criteria
of being an all-star?
- I've always been taught
winning takes care
of everything.
So my main focus coming
into a season is winning.
But I think with this year's
criteria,
people are, or were mad,
but I was first in fan voting,
I was second in, um,
the media,
and then I was third in peers.
So it's like, I don't know
what people, like,
should be mad about.
- Tell me your favorite all-star
moment that we don't know about.
- Oh, favorite all-star moment.
I mean, I think people
saw me and Giannis.
I was telling him
how he'd be traveling
and all this stuff on his euros,
and I thought he picked up
the ball before he took his,
his step with his left foot,
and then he'd take a euro.
It's quick, [snaps fingers]
but, like,
whenever he demonstrates it
to you slowly,
you understand
why it's not travelling.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:] Nutmeg time.
- [Trae:] Nutmeg time?
- Aight, bet.
- How did you learn the nutmeg?
- [Trae:] I was, I always, like,
do it with my dad,
messing around or whatever,
and he would always do it on me.
- So you play defense.
- All right.
- I always got to relax you.
- OK.
- Make you not, uh...
- But I'm up here.
- You up here?
- I'm up here.
I'm up here.
- Then you got to
go between your legs.
- [Laughs]
- I did it in the
All-Star Game with James.
- You did, but you did
like a,
it was crazy.
- [Trae:] He was turning...
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Trae:] ...so he was,
I was driving, so if you're
guarding me...
- Uh huh.
- ...and you're turning...
I'd always...
- Turning this way?
- [Trae:] I'd do it.
That's how I got the lay-up
or whatever, but...
- [Taylor:] OK.
And it's funny because even
when you did it to James, right?
Like you nutmeg him
and then he tries to,
like, do this,
but it's too late.
- Yeah, it's too late, it's too
late before you realize it.
- [Taylor:] OK.
Is there anybody
you want to nutmeg
that you haven't yet?
- Um, want to nutmeg?
I think people are seeing
it coming now,
but probably the best,
probably Bron.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- That'd be pretty cool.
- I know you're cooking some
stuff up
in the kitchen right now...
- [Trae:] Uh-huh.
- ...that you want to try.
- [Trae:] Yeah.
- Give me a little taste.
Like, what you're trying to,
what's some new moves?
- Well, here's a move
I did in high school.
It's on the three-point line.
I did this most of the time.
I took a dribble.
♪♪♪
- [Trae:] Yeah.
- Look at that.
- Seeing it here first.
- Yeah, you're seeing it here.
- [Taylor:] Can you ever be
an elite defender at your size?
- Uh, yes.
Um...
And for me,
being that is not going to be
a Pat Bev type of defender.
It's going to be elite
as far as just keeping my man
from out of the paint.
Um...
Being sneaky with steals,
being like a Chris Paul
type of defender.
Being like a pest.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:]
Trae Young with 50 points,
a new career high.
- [Taylor:]
So career high, 50 points.
- Mmhmm.
- That was fantastic.
- Congrats to you.
- I appreciate it,
appreciate it.
- You got the last laugh...
- [Trae:] Yeah.
- ...with the Miami Heat.
OK. What was going on
between you and Jimmy
throughout that game?
Any trash talk?
- [Trae:] No, wait, no trash
talk, wasn't nothing said.
Just, just two
competitive guys going at it.
- [Taylor:] But OK. Honestly,
after that first game
when you said "It's over,"
did you feel so silly?
- Oh, trust me.
- [Laughs]
- Trust me. I was sick.
- Yeah.
- I was sick.
I was...
when I said it was over,
we were up by 6 and...
- [Taylor:] A minute left.
- [Trae:] ...I got taken...
A minute left.
I got taken out.
We got a good shot off.
They came down, hit a three,
and tied it,
and I was like, "Oh, my gosh."
And I knew if we didn't
win that game,
people were going to talk
about that for a long time.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- And so, yeah, fast forward
and everybody was talking
about it for a long time.
- [Taylor:]
Al time three-point combo.
So you can pick
three players, all time.
- Yep.
- Um...
Steph would be in there,
Reggie Miller would be
in there,
and probably Ray Allen.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Trae:] Those three.
- [Taylor:] Right now you get
to make this dream team.
It can be current players
or past players.
- [Trae:] Mmhmm.
- Your starting five,
you're the starting point guard.
- OK.
- Tell me the dream four
around you.
- Dream four? Uh...
At my two guard,
I want Kobe.
My three, I would put LeBron.
At my four,
I would put KD.
Five, I put Shaq.
Shaq, I'd have to have
the big Diesel down there.
- [Taylor:] That's nice.
- [Trae:] That's
a tough starting five.
We would never lose.
- [Laughs] OK.
Who, is the hardest player
to defend in the league?
- [Blusters]
There's so many. Um...
Kyrie's probably the toughest.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Trae:] Kyrie's probably
the toughest
just cuz he's so shifty,
he can score.
He can, he can just make plays,
so probably, probably Ky.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:]
True or false and why?
You are afraid of birds?
- Oh, very true.
I just had crazy dreams
as a kid trying to figure out
what I would do
if it attacked me.
So for me,
I'm extremely afraid of braids.
- What'd you come up with?
How'd you get it off?
- Slap it.
- [Taylor:] [Laughs]
True or false and why?
You should make
the final Olympic roster?
- Um...false.
Um, I just think
my time will come.
as far as making the final 12.
I think, true, I should have
been on the list of the,
the people.
Um, I at least got to go out
into training camp...
- The 44, yeah.
- The 44. Um...
I don't think I should be
on the final roster.
I think those guys that,
those 12 guys,
the LeBrons, the Stephs,
I mean, I think it's their time
to, to keep it going,
so my time will come.
- [Taylor:]
OK, last segment.
I do this thing called
"On This Day You Posted."
- Mmhmm.
- [Taylor:] So I'm going to
show you a post.
- OK.
- You're going to tell me
why you posted it,
what you were thinking, what was
going through your mind.
- Okay.
- And I only have one for you.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
- I don't know if you are!
- Oh, snap. Oh, snap.
I think I have a feeling
of what it is.
- Okay, you ready?
- Oh, no, not this one.
- [Laughs]
- Not this video.
This ain't it.
And I got the hat on right now.
I'm kinda...
- You had to turn it.
- I was about to turn it back.
This is not,
this is not right.
All right. Turn it off.
Turn it off. Turn it off.
- It gets cringey, right?
- It gets crazy. It gets crazy.
- [Taylor:] So what was this?
What was this?
- I was, I think I may have been
an eighth grader.
- [Taylor:] You're so red.
- Yeah, I'm tripping right now.
- I think I was
an eighth grader,
maybe a ninth grader,
and I don't know why.
I don't know if I sent that
to my girlfriend back then
or what I did, and yeah, so...
- [Laughs]
- Yeah.
- And now it lives forever.
- Now it lives forever, so.
- That's the Internet.
- That's a lesson
that kids can learn.
Don't ever post something
because...
- [Laughs]
- ...you may regret someday.
It's not terrible.
There's worst things.
- That's for sure.
- It's just so meme-able.
- Yeah, facts.
- You can just always put it up,
anytime you do anything.
- It'll be a meme forever.
- Thanks for having me back
in Atlanta.
- Appreciate you having me.
- Thanks for your time.
- You have a great rest
of the season.
- All right. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
♪♪♪